[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara
guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem feiertag
die vom sport hand norbert lehmann beim
schottentor familie und das sind unsere
themen von heute
russische großoffensive in der ost
ukraine
gleichzeitig wird bundeskanzler scholz
die weltgemeinschaft ein putin darf den
krieg nicht verlieren nicht gewinnen
gedenken voller trauer und wut nach dem
amoklauf an einer grundschule in texas
streiten die usa über schärfere
waffengesetze und
auszeichnung für ihren mut drei
belarussische bürgerrechtlerinnen
bekommen für ihren kampf für freiheit
und gegen unterdrückung den karlspreis
das war natürlich eben ein ganz ganz
übler versprecher bitte bitte
entschuldigen sie das seit über drei
monaten wehrt sich die ukraine jetzt
gegen die russischen angreifer mit
großer kampfbereitschaft doch der
russischen großoffensive im osten des
landes haben ihre truppen offenbar nicht
mehr genug entgegenzusetzen
im donbass spitz ich die militärische
lage immer weiter zu noten leinhos und
christian volk berichten die ukraine
droht weitere großstädte im osten des
landes an putins truppen zu verlieren
die zwillings städte silvia ottow netz
konstanz mit zusammen 200.000 einwohnern
liegen unter dauerbeschuss wir sind den
angreifern deutlich unterlegen sagt der
ukrainische präsident
brauchen zeit und die hilfe unserer
partner vor allem waffen die volle
unterstützung ohne ausnahmen und
einschränkungen genug um zu gewinnen
tatsächlich stehen seattle oder netz und
ließ sich schon kurz vor der
einkesselung denn etwa südlich in pro
partner ist die russische armee bereits
durchgebrochen und den lehmann weiter
nördlich steht das offenbar kurz bevor
schon fest in russischer hand ist
zwitter oder erst über der
stadtverwaltung weg bereits die
russische flagge kämpfer der
selbsternannten volksrepublik tornetz
haben posten bezogen die ukrainische
seite bestätigt den verlust der heftig
umkämpften kleinstadt und es zeichnet
sich ab dass die regionen lohans und don
jetzt komplett verloren gehen
dann haben wir noch mario pohl und die
sogenannte landbrücke wo die ukraine
vielleicht versuchen werden im
gegenangriff ab herbst wieder land
zurückzunehmen in der zwillingsstadt
lucie jones kt ukrainische polizei die
arbeit der totengräber übernommen
beerdigungen können wegen der ständigen
russischen bombardements nicht mehr
stattfinden und so mussten in den
letzten tagen mehr als 150 kriegsopfer
provisorisch in einem massengrab
bestattet werden später sollen sie ein
ordentliches begräbnis erhalten
johannes hano ist für uns in odessa etwa
100 kilometer entfernt von der front wie
erleben sie im moment das
kriegsgeschehen und das vorgehen der
russen
also besonders brutal sind die kämpfe
natürlich im donners wir haben das er
gerade gehört aber der krieg wird hier
an vielen fronten gekämpft und es ist
auch ein terror krieg gegen die
zivilbevölkerung immer aktiv konnten die
russischen truppen zurückgedrängt werden
die menschen sind wieder auf die straße
gegangen aus ihren bunkern
herausgekommen wollten wieder zurück in
ein normales leben und da haben die
russen heute die stadt den stadtkern
runter artillerie feuer gelegt sieben
menschen sind gestorben 17 sind verletzt
worden das ist ein reiner terrorkrieg es
geht nur darum angst und schrecken zu
versetzen das gleiche passiert ihren
nikolov das ist das tor nach odessa auch
diese stadt wird jeden tag von raketen
mit streumunition unter feuer gelegt
auch dass keine militärische bedeutung
sondern einfach nur terror dann ziehen
sie hier unten im süden die russen
truppen zusammen kampfgruppen man geht
davon aus dass sie planen auch haut zu
marschieren im moment können sie das
noch nicht unter brigadekommandeur hat
uns gesagt sie mit großem werden sehr
wahrscheinlich kommen aber man braucht
jetzt ganz schnell und ganz dringend
schwere waffen das dauert alles viel zu
lange man müsse diese stadt hier halten
sonst geht odessa verloren
das johannes hano vielen dank
der bundeskanzler ist nach wie vor davon
überzeugt russland darf diesen krieg
nicht gewinnen und wird ihn auch nicht
gewinnen präsident putin habe bereits
jetzt alle seine strategischen ziele
verfehlt das sagte scholz heute auf dem
weltwirtschaftsforum in davos von dort
berichtet susanne biedenkopf
der bundeskanzler kam als letzter seine
rede der schlusspunkt in davos immer
wieder war die deutsche haltung zum
krieg thema gewesen auf den folien so
heute kaum neues bekanntes auch zu den
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine
erstmals überhaupt liefert deutschland
waffen in ein solches kriegsgebiet
darunter auch schweres gerät diese
unterstützung ist eng abgestimmt mit
unseren partnern und alliierten und auch
darin sind wir uns einig wir tun nichts
was die nato zur kriegspartei werden
lässt scholz sprach sich nachdrücklich
für internationalen freihandel und ein
meer ein internationaler zusammenarbeit
aus protektionismus und abschottung
seien keine option um es ganz klar zu
sagen die die globalisierung ist ein
holzweg sie wird nicht funktionieren
viele wirtschaftsvertreter hören dass
mit erleichterung auch der
vw-konzernchef eine welt der
blockbildung das mit sicherheit eine
schlechtere welt sind würden die welt
bremsen wir würden weniger entwicklungen
haben hürden weniger arbeitsteilung
haben in der welt das führt zu weniger
wachstum weniger wohlstand in der welt
auch zu mehr hunger zu mehr konflikten
der krieg hat das forum in diesem jahr
bestimmt zu spüren war vielerorts auch
ratlosigkeit
die zeitenwende ist über die westliche
welt gekommen ungefragt und unsortiert
die fragen liegen auf dem tisch jetzt
geht es für die welt-elite darum
gemeinsam neue antworten zu definieren
davon hängt nicht weniger ab als ihre
künftige glaubwürdigkeit
davos freund auf die prominenz ist
abgereist jetzt müssen den worten taten
folgen
rund 30.000 gläubige werden in diesen
tagen in stuttgart zum katholikentag
erwartet und auch dort ist der krieg in
der ukraine natürlich thema wie steht
die kirche dazu mischt sie sich genug
ein was es mit waffenlieferungen und dem
prinzip der gewaltlosigkeit aus
stuttgart berichtet petra auto
anna ist geflüchtet aus kiew in der
ukraine nach stuttgart im auto mit ihrem
enkel er hat schon vor langem seine
mutter verloren jetzt ist sein vater
gefallen im krieg
viele leute seiner brigade wurden
getötet auch er hatte eine
lebensgefährliche verletzung mein sohn
starb
es ist eines von vielen persönlichen
schicksalen und es wirft fragen auf die
auf dem katholikentag diskutiert werden
und zwar kontrovers wir helfen wieder zu
beitragen dass dieser krieg endet waffen
ja oder nein
da bin ich ganz klar positioniert die
ukraine muss unterstützt werden
andererseits ist auch klar mit jeder
waffe kann ich jemand töten ein dilemma
und viele hoffen hier auf dem
katholikentag antworten zu finden das
als kirche die wir die wir sehr
zufrieden stehen die wir uns für den
frieden einsetzen in der ganzen welt
nicht persönlich ehrlicherweise etwas
enttäuscht dass gegeben so wenig aussage
kommt und so wenig passiert
ähnlich sieht es auch die katholische
friedensbewegung pax christi kirche
mische sich viel zu wenig ein kirche
bischöfe müssen auch lauter werden
müssen sich positionieren und müssen
klar stellung beziehen wie man den
frieden in der ukraine wieder erreichen
kann
frieden in der ukraine
sie glaubt daran will wieder zurück zu
ihrem mann der es zu hause geblieben und
hilft die zerstörte stadt wieder
aufzubauen
19 kinder starben bei dem amoklauf an
einer grundschule in texas jetzt werden
immer mehr details über den täter
bekannt der 18-jährige soll das blutbad
kurz zuvor angekündigt haben unter
anderem in einer nachricht an eine junge
frankfurterin in die trauer mischt sich
zunehmend wut dass es in den usa immer
noch so leicht es an waffen zu kommen
mrt wissen
es reicht steht da weil sie genug haben
der kongress soll endlich die
waffengesetze verschärfen damit nicht
weiter kinder sterben durch sturmgewehre
in den händen von massenmördern mit
dabei abgeordnete und familien der opfer
des andy hug schulmassakers von 2012 die
zeit zu handeln wäre vor zehn jahren
gewesen als meine mutter in der
grundschule niedergeschossen wurde
auch gouverneur greg abbott von texas
ist unter druck weil er und seine
republikaner die waffengesetze lockerten
der störer bei der pressekonferenz ist
betrug der demokratische herausforderer
bei der gouverneurswahl im herbst er
wird heftig beschimpft
weil er die trauer stören
[Musik]
krank der gouverneur redet von geistiger
gesundheit aber wir lassen einen
18-jährigen ein sturmgewehr kaufen was
zur hölle dachten wir würde er tun wir
sind schuld
derweil gibt es neue details über den
täter ein überwachungsvideo zeigt ihnen
an einem zugang der schule offenbar
kündigte er per sms an eine jugendliche
in deutschland seine tat knapp zehn
minuten zuvor an die 15-jährige lasst
die nachricht deutlich später keine
chance etwas zu unternehmen die familien
in jever erwarten dass die politik jetzt
endlich die waffengesetze verschärft
noch gibt es momente wie bei der
gedenkfeier in denen sie alle vereint
sind in trauer aber die menschen hier
wissen dass gouverneur er wird am
freitag beim jahrestreffen der
waffenlobby nrw auftreten wird
zurück nach deutschland
aussenministerin annalena baerbock nennt
sie die mutigsten frauen europas die
drei belarussischen bürgerrechtlerinnen
die heute den internationalen karlspreis
bekommen
veronika zepp carlo svetlana tech allofs
kaya und maria kohl es nie koffer
führten vor zwei jahren die proteste
gegen den autoritären machthaber
lukaschenko an und zahlten einen hohen
preis zwei von ihnen gingen ins exil
maria kohl es nie koffer sitzt im
gefängnis über den tag in aachen jener
kunden
sie zählen zu den wichtigsten gesichtern
der demokratischen bewegung von belarus
für ihren widerstand gegen den
autokratischen machthabern lukaschenko
werden die drei frauen im ordner rathaus
mit dem karlspreis geehrt spidla nati an
oskar sagt du diese auszeichnung vereine
alle bälle russischen freiheitskämpfer
nico bauer
weil einheit unsere macht ist
lukaschenko und andere diktatoren wollen
die gesellschaften spalten unsere
einheit hält uns zusammen und gibt uns
mehr möglichkeiten druck auf das regime
auszuüben und uns gegenseitig zu
unterstützen
veronika zepp carlo und svetlana ich an
oskar leben im exil
die dritte preisträgerin maria kohl es
nie koffer ist in minsk inhaftiert beim
karlspreis in aachen wird sie von ihrer
schwester vertreten
ich weiß dass es für meine schwester
nicht einfach ist im gefängnis schon
seit fast 20 monaten ist maria dort aber
sie bleibt stark
außenministerin annalena baerbock hält
die laudatio würdigte den mut der frauen
armut lässt sich nicht wegsperren die
idee der freiheit kann man nicht ins
exil vertreiben
drei bälle russische frauen als vorbild
für viele menschen die heute in arten
ein zeichen setzen wollen für frieden in
europa
test bestanden das raumschiff von boeing
ist wieder zurück auf der erde
nach seiner reise zur internationalen
raumstation landete das unbemannte
raumfahrzeug in der wüste new mexikos
zuvor hatte es zahlreiche probleme
gegeben diese gelungene testflug es
lässt jedoch hoffen dass mit dem
starliner nun auch bald astronauten zur
iss gebracht werden können
und jetzt sport eishockey wm in finnland
norbert da ist die deutsche mannschaft
ausgeschieden ja ja schon etwas
enttäuschend denn das team das hatte er
die beste wm vorrunde seiner geschichte
hingelegt fünf siege in sieben spielen
brachten gruppenplatz zwei heute gegen
den sechsmaligen weltmeister tschechien
eine klare 1 4 niederlage
gerade mal zwei minuten sind gespielt
als die in rot gekleideten tschechien
durch pasternak in führung ging in der
gruppenphase noch enttäuschend zeigen
sie heute ihr mit abstand bestes match
und bauen ihren vorsprung durch schränke
auf 2 0 aus im zweiten drittel nach 32
minuten dann das vorentscheidende 3 0
durch klatschen der hoch verdiente
ehrentreffer durch moritz sei das feld
nach insgesamt drei unglücklichen
pfosten und lattenschüsse leider zu spät
ohne deutschen torhüter erzielen die
tschechen dann durchs michael den 4 1
endstand und stehen im halbfinale
während deutschland seit 69 jahren
weiter auf eine wm-medaille warten muss
an einen arbeitsfreien vatertag war
heute auch für das dfb team nicht zu
denken die deutsche nationalmannschaft
ist in marbella im trainingslager und
bereitet sich dort auf die kommenden
vier partien der nations league vor die
stimmung bestens mit anpacken und sich
trotzdem wohlfühlen der bundestrainer
erlebt die devise vor unter der man
dieses trainingslager treffend
zusammenfassen könnte hansi flick hat 26
spieler versammelt unter der sonne
südspaniens mit denen wir der ende des
jahres ins wm finale kommen
übergangsphase zwischen den der saison
und den nations league spielen und wir
konnten die vier tage wie ich hier
nutzen und dafür bin ich dankbar wir
nutzen die zeit schon um uns da so ein
bisschen darauf einzuschwören sowohl
natürlich technisch taktisch das was auf
dem platz passiert als auch einfach ein
gefühl zu kriegen dass uns diese nations
league spiele auch wichtig sind der spaß
sollte nicht zu kurz kommen und wird die
belgisch und manchmal etwas zu groß
geraten die nächsten gegner wie england
und italien sollten es möglichst nicht
sein
ja und gegen die italiener geht es beim
ersten nations league spiel nächste
woche samstag dankeschön galt noch der
blick aufs wetter das wird am brückentag
windig und teils stürmisch dabei kann es
im norden einzelne gewitter geben im
osten schauer sonst bleibt es trocken
bei 16 bis 23 grad viertel vor zehn ist
die zeit für das heute journal mit
marietta slomka wir wünschen nicht nur
aber vor allem den vätern noch einen
schönen vatertag danke für ihr interesse
und bis morgen wenn sie mitten auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]